dude look we got garyvee coming on this
is insane yeah cause given all the jokes
we've made about him you would think he
would never a simple [ __ ] these guys
surprised that he agreed to this in in
the first place and i'm really kind of
nervous about what the i don't know
tonally what it's gonna be i guess we'll
find out we will definitely find out
the man yes
boys there he is he's here
the one and only how are you man i'm
quite well how are you two guys we're
good man all the appearances you do man
everyone's always asking you to explain
things and give advice on things but no
one ever asks you man how are you doing
yeah that's very nicely i appreciate
that i am doing really well man when you
keep [ __ ] super simple it kind of works
itself out you know what does that mean
like what i think like i don't give a
[ __ ] about most [ __ ] as long as my
[ __ ] family's healthy like
the business stuff is like i love doing
it i'm so lucky that it's like my
natural you know i always think of like
skiers or painters or i genuinely
believe like if you're truly an
entrepreneur like i'm old you guys are
youngsters i'm 46 when i was coming up
entrepreneurship wasn't even a [ __ ]
word i never even heard it and i was
trying to sell lemonade and sell
baseball cards and go to garage you know
like it was what i liked it was my craft
it was like my art so
the fact that i like i'm good at the
thing that i naturally like doing the
most is such a [ __ ] you know you're
just that's like luck of the [ __ ] dna
game you know well you say we're
youngsters but you're 46 cody you're 50
ah
i'm a sprightly 31 actually thank you
very much let's appreciate that great
and great [ __ ] hair let's go really
who would debate that
i will he would he [ __ ] would you
know who he would yes he would just
because he's that's that's called
brotherly love when you're just such
boys yeah how much good [ __ ] is
happening one of the reasons i couldn't
wait to like do this with you guys is
like i'm so ridiculous as a communicator
like i think i'm the greatest fodder for
like laughs and so me and my boys are
that way that's how he is like anybody
that wasn't close to you would all agree
that your hair is the best but your boy
can be like your hair sucks [ __ ] yeah
and that sucks the problem is that's the
only person you believe is that guy
you're like [ __ ] man i am it does suck
it's receding a little bit god damn it
you know what's funny and i think you
guys know this in the context i think of
what you guys do so well there's
something so special
about like that inner circle that like
the love the razz the zinging and the hu
it's all just one same
macro like all love you know what i mean
a lot of people misconstrue my my
brutality for hate but it's love i
actually genuinely understand that hell
yeah okay here this actually is a good
segue into my next question because
please we so we dm'd on october 11th
when i asked you to do this damn and
then and then so we arranged this and we
said okay let's make it happen hit me on
the email whatever and then october 15th
you sent me a video of yourself it was a
tick tock that you did saying that uh it
was basically saying like you lose out
on opportunities by making fun of them
or being negative and then you said had
to do it and i just want to know do you
do you hate me oh i'm sorry i sent that
to like 25 people that i had just talked
to on dm i meant had to do it to society
that wasn't just to you
so i thought it was ultra targeted
me because you had seen like
you know something that we did and you
were like you know what he actually
needs to know this
this is uh yes that's the one i actually
think the way i do keynotes is so
affected by stand-up comedy and randy
the macho man savage
right like when i like i was like like i
was doing what i was doing and finally i
was like why is that how i do it and i
was like oh [ __ ] i used to listen to
stand up 24 7. and i watched wrestling
promo videos like it was my job and i'm
like oh [ __ ] subconsciously this is like
how i do [ __ ] and i think for me like
when now that i'm known enough that
people do [ __ ] about me
hey
i'm humbled
like this is crazy that i'm subject
matter for talented people and two if
you [ __ ] take yourself so [ __ ]
serious that you don't see when people
that actually have talent are doing [ __ ]
with it that you are so insecure that
you get mad or upset you're a [ __ ]
idiot damn
damn it's very easy for me to see who is
talented and being creative versus does
somebody have malicious intent and wants
to hurt somebody it's just i don't know
for me it comes very natural i'm not
even talking about me i'm just talking
like when you watch [ __ ]
that's creativity and pop culture oh
this person's hurting inside and just
wants to tear this other person it's so
crystal clear yeah so for me
no i mean i think you guys are genuinely
talented and i'm like
flattered for any time i'm in your
[ __ ] mouth damn that means a lot
honestly so you've seen demented garyvee
then yes okay good we wanted to ask you
what you thought i sometimes want to be
demented gary yeah
my mom did too
and making me nice but
i've seen it and and really and you know
this like you guys watched
i feel i'm making assumptions that you
guys are as good as you are because
you're watching everything in culture i
think that i have a [ __ ] funny
communication style that out of context
i think it's real funny real quick i
think i think that yeah like
like saying stuff like i want to rip my
arms off and what did you say in that oh
you said like kill your family or
something no no in the original takedown
before we go down this road can you just
can you just make my year and say
picture swallowing a bag of nails can
you just say that line mayonnaise of
nails i need you to picture yourself
swallowing a bag of
nails oh you're a legend you're a
[ __ ] legend for that
holy [ __ ] what's really funny about all
that stuff like i'll rip my arm off to
be 25 or you know how do i not worry
about dumb [ __ ] well imagine picturing
your family get you know
those are like me trying to like shake
somebody totally
said about like they gotta be on their
report card or their friend got a total
and they don't have one and i'm like bro
like think about this [ __ ] on the flip
side and this is where tick tock as a
format [ __ ] me i was like oh [ __ ]
people can stitch [ __ ] edit it the way
they want to
like you know yeah now you have people
armless bleeding out on tick tock and
they're like gary told me to do it and
now gary's on the other side like i
didn't tell you to do it i was just
using a metaphor man metaphors are
dangerous
right now and i'm a metaphor [ __ ]
machine so i'm in and and i'm uh like
let's be let's put [ __ ] in perspective
yeah dude right like you know how much
bad [ __ ] can happen and you're upset
about you didn't get the promotion like
every day on this earth people get very
upsetting news like really genuinely
upsetting news and i'm like [ __ ] man
just be grateful for what you have and
just the dumb [ __ ] that people cry about
yeah yeah i know get it what were you
going to say a second ago cody sorry
nothing i was just going to say it is it
seems like it's more effective
especially in in those mediums to use
hyperboles and to speak hyperbolic like
that where you're like because it makes
a great clip on some real [ __ ] this is
like what's fun back to like the friends
we were talking about the funniest [ __ ]
is like all my friends were like man i
wish the world knew that you've been
doing this [ __ ] like i've always been
ridiculous in my metaphors i don't
really have a different gear
i'm different contextually if we were
sitting down for an hour and you're like
hey we want to really blow this business
out yeah like how do you think about
what like you'd be like whoa that's a
different gary than we had on a podcast
because i go into like operations mode
and we're like you know it's like a
different it's a the context is
different in general like talking
differently has really been who i've
been my whole life mainly because i
failed every class and then not well
read i had to almost make up my own
language